bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission qui n'a pas été approuvé encore
par la préfecture mais qu'on va tourner
quand même
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de l'attractivité de la france
vis-à-vis des investissements étrangers
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode
de ses caches c'est un élément essentiel
au bon fonctionnement de notre économie
l'investissement étranger en 2019 la
france occupait la première place du
podium européen des investissements
étrangers avec plus de 1100 projets
annoncés aujourd'hui la france est elle
toujours aussi attractive
comment se comportent les investisseurs
face à la crise sanitaire les
entreprises étrangères ont elles un rôle
important à jouer dans la reprise de
l'économie ce sont ces questions qui
vont nous occuper dans cette émission et
pour cela nous serons en deuxième partie
avec frédéric boccara économiste et
membre des économistes atterrés de moins
30 à moins 40% cette année les
investissements directs à l'étranger
devraient plonger dans le monde en
raison de la crise liée aux coronavirus
selon les économistes de l'onu
une reprise est attendue pour 2022 alors
je vous le disais la france est le pays
d'europe qui a le plus séduit les
investisseurs étrangers en 2019
elle se place devant des pays comme
l'allemagne et le royaume uni alors
concrètement que représentent les
investissements étrangers en france on
voit cela avec le tiroir cash d'antoine
face
l'importance des entreprises orange air
n'est plus à démontrer en 2019
on estime que ce sont 13 % des salariés
en france qui travaillaient pour des
firmes sous contrôle étranger
cela représente quand même selon l'insee
plus de 2 millions de français c'est pas
rien la france s'était d'ailleurs
l'année dernière le pays européen le
plus attractif pour les entreprises
étrangères
avec 11% d'investissements
supplémentaires et 40000 emplois en plus
créé par rapport à l'année précédente
bref les étrangers exem bien la france
on peut s'en réjouir
c'est bon pour l'économie mais parce
qu'il ya un mais bien évidemment le
locaux vides
et n'allez pas croire que je fais une
fixette mais le coc vide remet un peu
tout à plat en europe tous les pays sont
touchés et d économie plombée et donc ça
refroidit fortement les investisseurs
étrangers qui sont au taquet sur les
plans de relance des différents pays
européens qui doivent pour les rassurer
faire de la pédagogie les brosser dans
le sens du poil en ordonnant en quelque
sorte des garanties sur le fait que
l'économie se portera bientôt lieu et
que c'est donc dans leur intérêt de
mettre de l'argent sur la table
c'est ce qu'a fait emmanuel macron avec
notamment ce sommet virtuel chose crâne
on peut difficilement faire plus clair
comme titre reste à savoir si ça
marchera en plein confinement une
cinquième en priorité pour les
entreprises françaises et on tente par
exemple de boli côté des entreprises
étrangères comme amazon
alors allez viens on vient de le voir
difficile de faire fonctionner une
économie sans investissements étrangers
jusqu'à quel point le modèle économique
français est-il tributaire de ses
investissements étrangers
c'est surtout qu' il faut quand même se
poser des questions toutes les
entreprises françaises partent à
l'étranger
c'est qu'a priori à un souci si elle
trouvait le pays si attractif ou en tout
cas avec la même attractivité que ne
l'ont les les entreprises étant
étrangère elle resterait et elle
investirait en france donc si elles
partent c'est que a priori il ya un
certain nombre de choses qui les font
partir alors est ce que c'est le coup
est-ce que c'est là la non stabilité
juridique et le le problème de d'avoir
des lois et des lois fiscales qui change
tous les quinze jours
est ce que c'est le le tout ce qui est
le droit social qui le droit du travail
en france qui est trop compliqué etc
bref il ya quand même beaucoup
d'entreprises et il ya aussi beaucoup de
jeunes qui partent à l'étranger et qui
part travailler à l'étranger
donc si on arrive à être aussi attractif
c'est bien qu'on donne des compensations
aux entreprises étrangères pour venir on
essaie de les attirer pour les attirer
on n'attire pas les mouches avec du miel
donc on essaie de faire en sorte que
l'investisseur est intérêt à venir en
france et qu'est ce que c'est que la
tyrrell attirer c'est lui donner des
franchise d'impôt lui donner un certain
nombre de garanties
comme quoi il va être mieux traités que
les entreprises françaises donc je suis
pas certain que il faille à tout prix
vouloir investir va faire investir des
entreprises étrangères au détriment des
entreprises françaises je pense qu'il
faudrait mieux essayer de faire rester
les entreprises françaises en france ça
serait plus intelligent
merci allez viens on passe tout de suite
à la deuxième partie de cette émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
avec frédéric boccara bonjour frédéric
boccara vous êtes économiste et membre
des économistes atterrés
bienvenue dans ses cageots pour
commencer on l'a dit en première partie
à la france était en 2019 le pays le
plus attractif d'europe pour les
investisseurs étrangers
l'année dernière le pays a concentré 18
7% des investissements venant de
l'étranger juste derrière on trouve le
royaume uni avec à 17 3% enfin en bas du
podium l'allemagne avec à 15,1 pour cent
frédéric boccara qu'est ce qui fait
selon vous que la france était très
attractive alors d'abord la france
attire beaucoup mais investit beaucoup à
l'étranger c'est ce que olivier
delamarche aussi a fait remarquer ça
veut pas dire qu'elle s'en vont mais
elles investissent aussi énormément la
france est l'un des premiers pays pour
ce qu'on appelle l'extraversion c'est à
dire la croissance relative à l'étranger
par rapport à la pas à la taille de
l'économie
alors qu'est ce qui attire les léser les
investissements étrangers en france
essentiellement d'après toutes les
enquêtes qualitatives qu'on fait c'est
pas tellement la fiscalité qui fait le
lfp le petit plus c'est le petit cerise
sur le gâteau de certain en tout cas
c'est essentiellement les services
publics la main d'oeuvre qualifiée
le fait que la france est au centre de
l'union européenne c'est une énorme zone
et puis aussi toutes les technologies
françaises à la fois les ouvriers
techniciens et ingénieurs qualifiés
l'écosystème scientifiques mais aussi
des technologies
quand general electric est un gros
investisseurs en france pas dans ses
projets parce que ça date d'il ya un peu
plus 4 5 7 ans achètent alstom achète
une partie d'alstom qui est liée aux
turbines ou à l'hydro et ben c'est la
technologie aussi et les marchés qui
sont derrière quand bombardier en
réalité achète alstom ce qui restait de
tgv
et on va voir une coentreprise avec
bombardier qui est dominant parce que
bombardier rachète les actions de bruit
qui voulait lui réalisé son pognon pour
faire simple et bien c'est le tgv la
marque tgv les marchés et la technologie
qui intéresse donc voilà c'est tout un
ensemble de qualités de la france et la
fiscalité c'est le petit truc qui vient
en plus donc je ne sais pas s'il faut
attirer ou pas attirer je pense qu'il
faut surtout mettre du contenu sur
l'attractivité et du contenu sur les
investissements à l'étranger et rentrés
sur des questions de contenu est ce
qu'on développe le pays ou pas olivier
juste en première partie évoqué le fait
qu'on pouvait donner l'impression aux
entreprises étrangères qu'on les
favorisés par rapport aux entreprises
françaises
qu'on l'ait traité d'une meilleure façon
est ce que c'est votre avis aussi
frédéric boccara sait pas exactement ce
qu'il a dit mais en tout cas on a
tendance à se dire et faire la danse du
ventre devant les investisseurs
étrangers
on voit bien emmanuel macron et vous ce
que vous avez montré ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui il a fait un truc à
versailles aussi en plein premier
compliment il se transforme il fait un
retour un show et pour attirer les
investissements étrangers en réalité
qu'est ce qui domine la technocratie
financière française qui domine qui est
là les rênes de commandes de notre pays
ces deux choses premièrement voilà c'est
je sais pas si c'est avec les patrons
qu'on le voit mais bon premièrement
qu'est-ce qui les domine c'est que les
grands groupes français les grandes
multinationales françaises qui
représentent la moitié des emplois des
entreprises elles doivent absolument se
développer à l'étranger est la
contrepartie pour qu'elle se développe
c'est d'ouvrir la france
voilà ça c'est le premier truc le plus
important en réalité qui pèsent sur
et il faut savoir que 5 millions
d'emplois en france dans les
multinationales françaises maison plus
de 5 millions à l'étranger
donc c'est énorme leur part à l'étranger
le pied à l'étranger est presque plus
fort que le pied en france et donc si on
veut que l'étranger s'ouvre il faut
ouvrir la france et donc c'est pour ça
qu'on va attirer les investisseurs
étrangers en france il ya les grandes
plan d'investissements étrangers
il ya aussi des petits investissements
qui sont des investissements de
portefeuille et qui sont très présents
dans les encres
reese parce qu'il ya un chiffre si vous
me permettez que vous n'avez pas cité
mais qui est que dans le cac 40 40 % des
actions du cac 40 sont détenus par des
non résidents
ça veut pas dire 40% des entreprises ça
peut être 40 % dans chaque donc à chaque
fois il ya 60% de capital français ça
peut être 80 dans l'une 20 dans l'autre
mais en tout cas il y à une myriade
d'investisseurs qui tournent des
entreprises françaises si vous prenez
sanofi par exemple dans sanofi l'oréal
qui détient le contrôle ne détient que
9% du capital et les investisseurs
étrangers détiennent 60 2 points 4 %
olivier on va reprendre les trois pays
du classement donc le royaume uni
l'allemagne et la france les prévisions
économiques aujourd'hui elles sont
plutôt favorables à quel pays je veux
dire par là est ce que la france peut
conserver à sa première place ou alors
est-ce que la crise du coronavirus est
en train de remettre tous les compteurs
à zéro
c'est en train de remettre tous les
compteurs à zéro et et particulièrement
en france je vous rappelle que le lait
le deuxième confinement va être mortelle
pour énormément d'entreprises donc je ne
suis pas sûr que la mariée soit si belle
que ça
à la sortie du cog hill donc puis à une
petite remarque je voudrais faire par
rapport à à ce qu'a dit notre notre
invité il ya il faut quand même faire
une différence entre une entreprise qui
vient m
qui vient mettre une unité de production
en france et qui investit en france et
qui crée du travail en france
et puis un general electric qui achètent
alstom et qui maintenant à la main sur
sur nos centrales nucléaires parce que
les turbines d'alstom et nous ne nous
deux souveraineté sur notre production
d'énergie et que maintenant c'est les
américains qui ont les clés
alors là moi je suis contre est
absolument contre les investissements
étrangers si ça se passe comme ça et
c'est ce que c'est ce qu' en train c'est
ce qu'est en train de faire macron sûr
il l'a fait sur alstom maintenant ils
essaient de le faire sur sur l'eau et
puis plus tard sur sur d'autres sur
d'autres sociétés vous avez une société
d'optronique militaire qui est aussi en
train de partir aux etats-unis enfin on
en arrête pas aujourd'hui de donner les
clés de nos fleurons à des à des
entreprises étrangères donc que là je
suis pas sûr que le le fait d'avoir le
plus d'investissements étrangers soient
réellement la chose à faire et qu'il
faille s'en glorifier vous êtes d'accord
investissements étrangers et oui mais
pas n'importe lesquels elle totalement
en fait on voit bien que au prétexte
enfin pas au prétexte
en réalité pour appuyer les grands
capitaux français qui vont faire
l'argent partout de façon égoïste on est
prêt à brader effectivement une maîtrise
nationale s'est pas exactement une
souvent des éléments dessous va t et une
maîtrise nationale et des possibilités
de coopération
donc c'est extrêmement grave même s'il
ya besoin de dépenses croisés moi je
crois que ce qui est important de voir
il ya deux choses qu'on pourrait voir la
première c'est que aujourd'hui comme il
ya des coûts fixes de recherche comme il
ya toutes ces nouvelles technologies
information révolution informationnelle
ou
brevet il peut être utilisé et coûte pas
plus cher s'il utilisait sur une échelle
très grande ou sur la moitié d'une
échelle à voir donc des entreprises très
grandes multinationales sa partagent les
coûts mais au pour partager les coûts on
ne fait pas une partage des coûts ont
fait une prédation une trésor contrôle
et on vend à l'encan donc on pourrait
très bien avoir des accords de partage
sans d'ailleurs de dépenses en capital
financier etc avec des conditions qui
permettent dé développement d'emplois
dans les différents territoires des pays
concernés recherche etc
c'est ce qu'était airbus pendant de très
nombreuses années
en réalité quand c'était un génie bon
bien une deuxième chose qui est
importante c'est qu'effectivement
l'investissement au sens de la création
de capacités de production nouvelles
l'installation des tables y sont et
c'est pas la même chose que ce que les
statistiques appel investissements
directs et mises d'argent et mises
d'argent pour prendre le contrôle
alors en plus il peut y avoir quelque
chose de terrible on peut observer un
désinvestissement qui correspond au fait
que l'entreprise et c'est ce qui est en
train de faire general electric sur
l'hydroélectricité peut-être demain sur
le nucléaire
l'entreprise se retire et donc on voit
moins d'investissements mais en réalité
elle a entre temps déplacer les brevets
les technologies les savoir-faire en
suisse ou ailleurs et donc elle a s'est
retiré en emportant des choses
principales donc il ya une vraie
question majeure qui est posée derrière
ces investissements étrangers mais les
partages de dépenses sont nécessaires et
finalement ces on-dit l'économie
française a pas assez de financements
c'est pour ça qu'il faut attirer les
financeurs étrangers et dans
l'investissement étranger je rappelle
qu'il ya aussi les investissements de
portefeuille qui pèse un poids important
dans toutes nos entreprises
mais si on va marquer une courte pause
et on revient dans un instant
mais emmenés dans ces caches si vous
nous rejoignez cette semaine on parle
des investissements étrangers pour cela
nous sommes en liaison avec frédéric
boccara économiste et membre des
économistes atterrés
olivier un petit mot sur cette étude du
cabinet restait nyon qui a interrogé à
des investisseurs fin avril 80 % d'entre
eux ont déclaré que la nature et
l'envergure des plans de relance
pèseront l'heure des arbitres des
arbitrages pardon sur la localisation de
leurs investissements prenons l exemple
de la france
concrètement son attractivité
aujourd'hui va principalement se jouer
sur ces plans de relance ou alors est-ce
que d'autres paramètres peuvent peuvent
aussi poser
écoutez les plans de relance on voit
très bien où ça on est je vous rappelle
que aujourd'hui le plan de relance par
exemple européen et est à l'eau
ça avait été annoncé je vous rappelle à
grand renfort de victoire du
gouvernement actuel
et il est à l'eau parce que vous avez
quelques pays qui ne le vote pas ils ont
bien raison d'ailleurs de ne pas le
voter donc aujourd'hui
on a on a un plan de relance qui est
inquiétant pas maintenant les plans de
relance purement français si vous voulez
on peut pas on peut pas appuyer dans une
voiture en même temps sur le fin sur
l'accélérateur ça marche pas d'autant
plus que ces plans de relance ne sont
que ce qu'ils sont c'est à dire
principalement de donner accès à
certains secteurs à de la dette et est
donc essayer de régler un problème de
l'endettement par part de l'endettement
ça leur fournira pas de l'activité non
plus et donc ils seront ils seront avec
leurs dettes et sans on semble pouvoir
faire grand chose donc non non bien sûr
que c'est pas le c'est pas le plan de
relance ou en tout cas les les
différentes entreprises ferait bien de
réfléchir un tout petit peu avant de se
lancer dans des investissements massifs
la investir c'est très bien mais il faut
que vous ayez quelqu'un en face pour
acheter ce que vous le ce que vous allez
produire donc
et aujourd'hui c'est bien le problème
c'est que on a on a 1000 le l'économie
française à genoux visiblement ça n'est
pas fini si on écoute monsieur castex et
monsieur macron on va donc continuer
comme ça et bien quand vous avez un pays
à genoux il a du mal à se relever même
si vous investissez comme vous voulez
dedans il faut trouver en face à des
gens qui est non seulement envie
d'acheter mais en plus qu'ils aient les
moyens de le faire or ça va pas être
facile à trouver
frédéric boccara une réaction on l'a dit
un an pendant la crise sanitaire et a
mis en place toute une série de mesures
pour contrer justement cette crise y est
aux côtés de 19
est-ce que c'est des mesures qui sont
selon-vous suffisante pour rassurer ses
investisseurs
c'est pas c'est pas moi je partage
l'idée que c'est un problème de contenu
des mesures d'abord alors on a une
situation spécifique où il faut pas
seulement traiter la demande aussi
l'offre c'est-à-dire la production mais
on traite l'offre dans ce que ces plans
de relance qui d'ailleurs sont beaucoup
moins gros que ce qu'on dit il ya
beaucoup d'effets d'annoncé on les
traite essentiellement pour regonfler le
capital et les profits mais pas
consolider les capacités de production
et de recherche
or si on voit ce qui est devant nous et
qui peut permettre
disons un développement sain
internationale un co développement avec
des investisseurs étrangers parce qu'il
peut y avoir un autre type de
mondialisation c'est ce qui se posent
devant nous aussi en réalité qu'est ce
qu'il faudrait développer les capacités
de tous les ingénieurs les techniciens
et d'ouvriers des travailleurs des
employés il faut développer leurs
capacités dont pas seulement dire on
fait du chômage partiel est louis
congelant
mais en des plans de formation
considérable or le plan castex pour ne
prendre que celui là sur 100 milliards
bien que 1 milliard c'est à dire 1 % qui
est consacré à la formation
professionnelle
deuxièmement il faudrait lancer beaucoup
plus de façon très simple un
développement de recherche développement
ou de réflexion sur des projets
c'est-à-dire pour la suite effectivement
une offre qui avec du crédit va demain
créer une certaine demande et va demain
créer une production donc des projets de
recherche les projets développement en
lien avec des productions localisé entre
guillemets et troisièmement il ya il
faut s'appuyer sur nos atouts qui sont
l'écosystème deux services publics du
pays est il précisément aujourd'hui
celui de la santé qui est quand même qui
bat de l aile l'éducation la recherche
donc un plan qui dirait banco sur santé
éducation recherche
ah oui ça permettrait aussi de
consolider la venue des investisseurs
après il ya un élément de coûts on peut
effectivement mettre en avant tout la
masse du crédit avec une sélectivité en
baissant le coût du crédit voire négatif
pour les investissements qui vont
développer la base française ou qui vont
co développer la base de l'investisseur
et la base française
ça c'est un élément positif en poussant
europe des accords de coopération qui
permettent des partages de coûts donc on
va baisser les coûts au lieu d'avoir une
europe qui est sûre le couple soit
concurrence soit monopole et du coup
alstom pour reparler d'alstom qui se
rachète par bombardier alstom les gens
ne le savent peut-être pas pas développé
un train non pas un tgv est met un train
ter si vous voulez à hydrogène donc qui
polluent 0 il n'y a même pas besoin de
medair des lignes électriques donc ça
pollue aussi - donc qui polluent 0 et ce
train à hydrogène qui est développé par
alstom dans la fugea à bombardier pour
des dogues de concurrence et de risque
de monopole de la commission européenne
et belle somme va être obligé de vendre
ce tgv ce train à hydrogène et bien si
au lieu d'être des prises de contrôle
financière on avait des accords de
coproduction et de partage on n'aurait
pas ces problèmes de monopole et donc on
n'a pas besoin de revendre un certain
nombre d'atouts donc il ya ces problèmes
de cou qu'on peut traiter par des
partages de coûts ou le dépenser deux
milliards en achat financier on partage
des coûts
par des nouveaux crédits et puis de
l'autre côté en appuyant des bonnes
choses ce qu'on ne veut pas sélectionnés
ne pas se rendre compte de ce qui est
bon chez nous en france
c'est ça qui pose problème olivier à
début novembre emmanuel macron à
discuter avec huit patrons de groupes
étrangers objectif pédagogie donc avec
le plan de relance de la france et
opérations à séduction aussi est-ce que
ce contexte de crise sanitaire risque
aussi d'exacerber les rivalités entre
les pays notamment notamment au sein de
l'union européenne
bien sûr on l'a vu on a bien vu quand
même depuis le début de cette histoire
que l'europe était une blague
on nous a vendu un couple
franco-allemand depuis des années en
nous disant qu' on était heureux qu'on
couché ensemble qu'on s'embrasse et
qu'on travaillait ensemble et c'est là
qu'est ce qui s'est passé au moment du
coc vide au moment du coc vite chacun à
tirer pour çà çà çà son pays et et on a
fait c'était dû chacun soit et ce qui
est normal d'ailleurs dans un dans un
contexte qui est compliqué il ya un
repli automatique des dpi sur sur leur
le rôle problématique personnelle et
donc on a bien vu qu'il y avait pas
d'europe ça n'existe pas c'est chacun
pour soi et donc vous allez avoir mis en
effet à la sortie de tout ça vous allez
avoir des pays qui seront au tapis et
des pays qui seront un peu moins au
tapis mais qui vont pas à aider leurs
petits camarades à se relever parce que
parce que c'est à ce moment là c'est la
guerre je veux dire chacun pour soi et
on va pas s'amuser à tendre la main et
vous verrez que
on ne tendra pas la main à chaque fois
que on a on nous a vendus on nous a
communiqué sur une une sur une
initiative commune regardez donc le plan
de relance européen
moi je vous ai dit à ce moment là on
avait reçu un invité qui était sûr que
ça y est c'était le début de la grande
europe
j'avais beaucoup rigolé à ce moment là
en disant que non le plan de relance il
n'était pas voté et qu'il n'était pas
prêt de se faire et en fait je suis
désolé d'avoir raison il n'est pas près
de se faire donc on voit bien que les
les pays n'ont pas du tout envie de
collaborer ensemble et que les pays
c'est du chacun pour soi et donc cette
crise ne va faire qu exacerber les
tensions
c'est une évidence alors on peut faire
la danse du monde comme le fait monsieur
macron mais je suis pas sûr que ça
fonctionne
frédéric boccara très rapidement une
réaction puisque nous reste moins d'une
minute est ce que des pays comme la
france ou l'allemagne n'aurait pas
plutôt allé gagner à faire front commun
pour sécuriser ses investissements
étrangers
alors ce qu'il faut c'est sécuriser
l'emploi et les réponses publiques pour
les gens et leurs revenus
en fait ce qui va s'exacerber c'est on
va exacerber les tensions entre pays
mais en réalité c'est les patrons et
c'est le capital qui veut exacerber les
tensions parce que les gens voudraient
coopérer et c'est cette question je
dirais de classe suis désolé de le dire
ou c'est tout pour le capital ou du
partage entre les gens la banque
centrale européenne est obligé de mettre
des centaines de milliards et ça il faut
jamais l'oublier mais beaucoup plus que
la variation du budget national
mais pour ça passe par les marchés
financiers le délai dont ça ne développe
pas les services publics donc sur le
vaccin il va falloir partager va falloir
pas être en rivalité sur sa logistique
sur les recherches il faut pousser la
diversité des approches c'est parce
qu'on a parce que le capital veut faire
rentrer tout le monde dans une union
sacrée prétendument des peuples au nom
du national alors qu'en réalité il doit
y avoir une union des peuples sur les
intérêts des peuples des travailleurs
des services publics de tous les
habitants et pas sur les profits et le
capital on a besoin de l'argent mais pas
au service du capital au service du
développement des gens la planète des
ressources et de la créativité des
recherches
et ça c'est l'enjeu qui est devant nous
des institutions pourrait porter sa tout
autrement et c'est ce qui est posé les
questions de la mondialisation
merci merci merci beaucoup frédéric
boccara d'avoir été parmi nous dans
cette émission je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste et membre des économistes
atterrés
olivier on passe aux questions cash et
olivier on commence tout de suite avec
la question de anthony à 83 olivier
diriez-vous aujourd'hui que les
entreprises comme amazon son pub plus
puissante que les états c'est un fait
c'est factuellement apple amazon
les gars femmes en général sont des
entreprises qui en termes de de
trésorerie en terme d'heures sont plus
puissantes
aujourd'hui et en termes de
renseignements sur vous n'oubliez jamais
que ce sont des machines à collecter des
données sur vous sont bien plus
puissante qu'un étang merci olivier
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas de poser
toutes vos questions à olivier sur les
réseaux sociaux ou en commentaire des
vidéos et puis pour voir ou revoir nos
précédents numéros direction à notre
site internet à l'adresse rt france
point tv on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine et en skate olivier avec le
mot de la fin
attention l'investissement n'est pas
toujours pavé de bonnes intentions